the decision you make of your career for
those of us who are lucky enough to have
a choice over careers it's arguably the
biggest Choice you'll make in your life
certainly one of the biggest choices and
I set up this organization back in 2011
called 80 000 hours we chose that number
because it's approximately how many
people how many hours people work over
the course of their life so if you think
40 years 40 hours a week 50 weeks a year
it's 80 000. choosing that number just
to get across like this is a big
decision you know one percent of that is
20 weeks you know do people spend 20
weeks thinking about their career like
probably not like certainly I didn't so
the first thing is just really think
about this if you're a kind of young
person